Speaker 1: With Republicans taking over the House
of Representatives, we expect that the current
House minority leader, Kevin McCarthy, is going
to become the next speaker of the House. In fact,
he got the nomination of his party earlier this
month by a wide margin, 188 to 31, getting many
more times the votes that his challenger,
Andy Biggs, got. But even so, McCarthy is
going to have a tough time getting to that 218
vote threshold that you need to become speaker
when that vote takes place on the House floor at
the start of next year. And that's because he has
a slim majority to work with. Democrats are, of
course, going. To back Pelosi's successor. Hakeem
Jeffries But he's not going to have the 218 votes
that he needs. Republicans are going to have to
decide among themselves who the next speaker of
the House is. So McCarthy will need nearly all
the votes from the Republican caucus to get him
to that 218 threshold. He can only spare to have
about four Republicans vote against him. That's
the current projection based on how some of these
elections are playing out and how big the majority
is going to be for the Republicans. And that's
going to be a tall task for McCarthy, getting
those 31 Republicans who voted against him in the
nomination process to vote for him to speaker on
the House floor. He can only afford to lose a few.
And right now, he's got to convince at least a few
dozen of them. We already have a number of hard
no's from Republican reps saying that they're not
going to be backing McCarthy. Many of these hard
no's come to us from the House Freedom Caucus.
They include people like Matt Gaetz, Ralph Norman,
Andy Biggs, Matt Rosendale and Representative
Bob Good. Interestingly enough, Marjorie Taylor
GREENE not on this list. You'd think that she's
so fringe that of course she would back whoever is
running against McCarthy. But maybe because she's
being promised her committee assignments back,
she is saying McCarthy is the person for the
job right now. And even among these hard no's,
are they actually hard nosed? Like they're
probably just using this for leverage in a
negotiation. The idea is that maybe they'll end
up giving their votes to McCarthy in exchange for
some concessions. Like one thing that's being
floated in particular is to institute a motion
to vacate the chair, which would allow members
of the House to kick out the current Speaker of
the House mid-session. So if they got this in,
potentially what would happen would be McCarthy
gets elected speaker, he gets enough votes, and
then after a short period, a period of time,
the Freedom Caucus gets upset with him and decides
to oust him as their leader. He's apparently not
in negotiations yet with the Freedom Caucus, but
his hand is eventually going to be forced, that
he's going to have to come to the table and talk
to these people if he wants their votes. McCarthy,
we know, has one of the speakership. For so long
it's been his ultimate goal and his career. And he
nearly got it in 2015 when John Boehner decided to
step down as the leader of the House, Republicans
stepped down as speaker of the House. But then it
became clear that McCarthy was not going to get
the votes that he needed to become speaker. So in
came Paul Ryan, who was ushered in as someone who
could represent, like the Tea Party factions
and the Freedom Caucus factions, while still
having appeal to like the broader Republican Party
because he was Mitt Romney's VP candidate in 2012.
And so he was the one guy everyone could agree
on. There's talk about that type of situation
happening against McCarthy and instead someone
like maybe Steve Scalise or Elise Stefanik or Jim
Jordan coming in as the person that Republicans
can all coalesce around. Now, another thing that
may damage McCarthy is that he seems unwilling
to impeach Joe Biden because he kind of gets the
political ramifications that could happen if they
decide to impeach Biden for some absurd reason,
especially because Biden hasn't really done
anything impeachable over these past couple of
years, especially, you know, relatively speaking,
in terms of what you would impeach a president
for. Some say that he should be impeached for
pulling out of Afghanistan. Some on the right are
saying that he should be impeached for inflation,
some say for Hunter Biden and the laptop from
hell. It's clear the base just wants to impeach
Biden because of revenge. And they figure, okay,
well, Trump got impeached twice, so we got to
impeach Biden in the same way. But that could
end up backfiring hugely for them if it's seen as
being done for a nonsense reason. And I kind of
get the sense that Kevin McCarthy understands that
he wants to avoid avoid impeachment altogether if
he's able to. But if people are saying from
inside the House that you've got to do it,
if the constituents, the Republican Party,
you're saying you've got to do it, maybe his
hand will be forced. You don't have to do that.
So Kevin McCarthy in a giant mess. I don't envy
his position right now. It's not a shoo in that
he's going to become the next House speaker,
but he's certainly vying for it and we'll see if
it ends up happening. We're going to go to a break
right now. We'll be back with much more of the
David Pakman show after these commercial messages.